hello everyone and welcome to the first
part of the basic introduction to hall
from system modeler that we will be
going over today from John you have
already learned how system modeler can
be used in various different ways
and what it can be used for now we will
jump right on to seeing how we can
actually use the software my name is
Patrick Eikenberry
and I will be going over this in three
parts and you'll learn how to get
started with wall from system modeler
between each part we will open it up to
questions
but however feel free to type any
questions you might have into the chat
window and we will also try and answer
them as they come up this notebook that
I have here will be distributed in the
chat window so you can download it for
yourself
and follow along with the tutorial in
this first part we will introduce
ourselves with the software will look at
ready-made models there are runnable
examples that are available in system
modeler and we'll find out how we can
explore them we will also simulate the
example model and manipulate it in
different ways I will start by yumping
into a new session of system modeler
when you open up sister muddler for the
first time you will be greeted with a
welcome screen if the welcome screen
does not appear you can manually open it
by going to help and selecting welcome
screen from the toolbar from here you
have direct access to different videos
to get you independently started with
system modeler the one to two minute
videos modeling simulation and analysis
will give you the fastest possible
introduction to system obler from here
you're also able to see the latest
features go to the documentation Center
find ready-made models and examples and
find more resources such as this
training course first head into the
documentation center by clicking the
documentation icon the vol front system
modular documentation center provides
you with a manual describing the
different parts of system modeler
under getting started you can find text
driven tutorials with step-by-step
instructions ranging from how to set up
the software to how to create advanced
systems of models
here you will also find documentation
for the different sub libraries
available in system habla
after exploring the documentation center
you can go ahead and close both this
window and the welcome screen you will
now explore the modeling environment of
system modeler called model center when
starting up system modeler a blank
diagram will be displayed in the middle
of the window this is the canvas on
which models will be created surrounding
the diagram different toolbars and
browsers will help you create models for
this tutorial we'll be using a
scaled-down interface in the toolbar go
to View window layout and select modeler
this will remove several toolbars we
won't be using here you can switch
between different layouts at any time
in model center you'll find the class
browser to the left here you can find
ready-made example models under the
examples tab you will also find
pre-built parts for you to use when
modeling systems visa funds in the
packages listed in the library tab
click the arrow next to package to open
it up and explore it further the
education examples and industry example
packages contain complete models from
different educational and industrial
domains
in this tutorial we'll explore a model
from the introductory example packages
click the arrow next to it and locate
the inverted pendulum model under the
system's
sub package
double-click the inverted pendulum model
to open it the model will be opened in
the diagram view of system modeler
you can see here that the diagram
consists of four different components a
controller a motor opinion and a
pendulum between the components are also
connection lines the gray in green
connection lines indicate physical
connections the shaft of the motor forms
a solid connection to the rotational
part of the pinion while the
translational part forms a solid
connection to the cart of the inverted
pendulum the blue connection lines form
directional signal connections the
direction of the signals are indicated
by the arrow at the base of the
connection
component
census of other models and they can
themselves contain components to explore
a model behind the component you can
double-click it to enter it
explore the motor component in this way
inside the motor component you'll see a
new type of connection line a light blue
indicating an electrical connection on
the far left a variable voltage source
determines the voltage over the circuit
in the main model the signal determining
the voltage was connected to controller
on the far right an electro motoric
force component converts an electrical
current into a torque when you have
finished exploring the sub model you can
exit it by clicking the up arrow icon
it is now time to simulate the inverted
pendulum model simulate the model simply
press the play button in the toolbar
this will automatically both build and
simulate your model
the model will be sent to the simulation
environment of sister Matla called
a simulation center when running a
ready-made model one or more plots will
be directly shown in the plot window
this is known as a default stored plot
and it will be displayed immediately
after the model has been simulated the
stored plots are predefined plot setups
they indicate the most important
variables to explore in a model stored
plots are listed in the stored plot menu
on the left hand side of simulation
Center build entries indicate a default
stored plot
besides the variables found in store
plots you can access all variables in
model from the plot tab the variables
are sorted under the different
components and subcomponents you can
expand a component by clicking the small
arrow next to it add a plot of the
torque produced by the motor to do this
you first need to add an empty plot you
can either choose to add a subplot to
the existing plot tab or add a
completely new plot tab try adding a new
subplot by clicking the corresponding
button in the toolbar
next find the talk variable of the motor
component by expanding motor EMF one and
flange in turn with the new empty plot
selected check the box next to the tau
variable the variable will be plotted in
the selected plot window
for 3d mechanical systems and animation
of the simulation is automatically
created to access this animation press
the animation button in the toolbar you
can navigate in the 3d environment by
holding and dragging the mouse pointer
you can traverse it by holding the
control key while dragging the mouse
pointer we used the scroll wheel on your
mouse to zoom in and out plus the play
button to start the animation
during animation a line will be
displayed in the plots indicating the
current plot time
such as stopping the simulation toggling
it to repeat infinitely and selecting
the time scale
you
click the blue part of the pendulum in
3d animation window and the
corresponding component will open up in
the plot tab of simulation center
create a parametric plot of the x and y
position of the pendulum tip to do this
create a blank parametric plot window by
clicking the corresponding button in the
tool box with the pendulum cylinder
opened expand the frame translation
component followed by frame B then in
order select the r01 variable which
corresponds to the tips x position
followed by our underscore 0 2 which is
the y position to test a new set of
parameters switch from the plot tab to
the parameters tab change the value of
the motor resistance by expanding motor
and navigating to the field that is
labeled R type in 4.8 then reasonably
the model by clicking the play button
notice how the plot changes shape
often it is of interest to compare two
or more sets of parameters to each other
in simulations and you can do this by
duplicating an experiment right-click
the inverted pendulum in the experiment
browser and select duplicate
you now have two copies of the inverted
pendulum experiment the second copy has
not been simulated yet
before running the experiment switch
back to the parameters view and expand
the motor component
notice that the our parameter is
displayed in bold and the return arrow
next to the input field this indicates
that the parameter has been changed with
respect to the value in the mul click
the return arrow to reset it to the
model definition now go ahead and
simulate the duplicated experiment by
pressing the play button the default
plot angle and position for the second
simulation will open up in a new tab
compare the old experiment to the new
one
switch to the parametric plot that you
created previously by selecting the
corresponding tab
in the experiment browser you will see a
list of suggested plot variables these
correspond to recently plotted variables
click the first and the second suggested
float variable in order and the
parametric plot will appear in the plot
window
in the next tutorial we'll learn how to
create a model from scratch using
drag-and-drop before we open it up to
questions
let me quickly recap what we just did we
explored some different parts of model
center and simulation center by looking
at and included example model we looked
at things such as the documentation
center how to access model diagrams and
how to explore components of a model
then we started a simulation of the
model and plotted various variables from
that simulation and also viewed an
animation of the system so with that
let's open it up to you questions so if
you have any questions so far now is the
time to ask them thank you